what's your relationship I mean we
always hear that you and Cube don't have
much of a relationship but is there any
sort of like World in which you guys get
together maybe do another West Side
connection have a conversation like I
said earlier I [__] with who [__] with
me
um you dig that's where I'm at with it
if you [__] with me I'll [__] with you
but if it's [__] me it's [__] you like I
don't I [__] with who [__] with me kill
you know what I'm saying and um I ain't
seen him or talked to him and damn near
20 years so there it is that's so crazy
what about Dub C
so man it's just
man y'all got Classics together bruh I
totally understand Classics I totally
get it but you know that's I'm just the
kind of guy that you know I rock with
who rock with me I respect that man yeah
I I think most people should live by
that by that law yeah for sure yeah